[Music]
in my opinion you're the front-runner
right now the voice is so smooth Robin
Thicke is not wrong a front-runner guys
front runner with smooth vocals and
right off the bat we want to let you
know we were admittedly wrong we have a
new hypothesis about who we think is
behind the mask of the kangaroo but
first welcome to unmasking the masked
singer tonight we're gonna be running
down all the singing celebs the new
clues and decoding all the evidence I'm
Deidre Behar and I'm Charlie O'Keeffe
before we get into all that let's take a
look at tonight's elimination
ladies my god comedian the one and only
true
drew Carey drew Carey and Adrienne
Bailon houghton you guys right it is
such a treat to have you here with us
tonight be here thank you guys for
having course you crushed it on the mask
singer last season we know you've gotten
vocal prowess you four days so we're
gonna have you stick around if you don't
mind Morgan we're gonna dig into
everything first of all reaction to Drew
Carey okay I was shocked I was like uh
this guy is not a professional singer
which I actually do love I think it's so
awesome when you see somebody kind of
step out the box and do something
different and it was shocking to me but
at the same time I was like let me find
out Drew has vocals okay come through it
was actually still really good 100%
while we still have four mass celebs in
the competition so let's take a look at
miss monster who gave us a very fancy
performance this
[Music]
[Applause]
don't
so good okay so did you know immediately
who this was good night okay I think
actually my husband was the one that
first pointed it out and once he pointed
out I was like okay I'm just saying now
I'm definitely just part of the regular
community of people guessing as well and
I do believe that this is Chaka Khan
yeah okay so again we're still warming
up it's still the beginning of the
season we thought it was Tanya Tucker
country's edgy yeah no I'm sorry I love
you guys she's saying if you are a real
Chaka Khan fan you know that Chaka Khan
yeah and she's every woman it's all a
turn look well it's funny you bring that
up you know there was a clue tonight
that she's really doing this to be equal
with mr. monster and to show the world I
am every not in so many words I am every
yeah but and so I felt like you know
what she's a woman she can do it all in
that vent classic jam with Whitney
Houston kind of says it all was a look
loose tipped you off
breaking down the clue package we saw a
queen chess piece it was on one of the
drawing boards there right at the start
she is obviously the queen of thunk I
mean you can see it right there yeah a
small clue but I think it's a big one
100% the other big thing that tipped me
off was the butterfly drawing which you
can see on the on the clipboard there if
we can pull that what does that mean
the butterfly drawing so I'm like what
is butterfly well she has a song from
1980 called Papillon aka hot butterfly
so Papillon Islands is Franklin for
butterflies that Blaine this lady got
married and then she sang fancied by
Reba McEntire they were actually
inducted into the Hollywood Bowl Hall of
Fame together in 2012 so I don't know I
feel like I feel like you've got the
vocal expert opinion here that's
definitely shot guys go listen to some
shocked records and you'll be like yeah
and something new they actually did
tonight we saw most likely voted Clues
so for for Chaka who we are guessing
most likely to be in the presence of
royalty we actually have a photo of her
meeting the Queen this was a few years
ago in 2009 at the Royal Variety
Performance
that's to me that definitely makes sense
to me
Wow so music royalty
real royalty it's all working and next
up we have the white tiger who certainly
brought the Good Vibrations with his
performance tonight check it out all
right
do you have any idea no clue who that is
like not even the slightest clue really
yeah like some of them obviously again
I'm just part of the regular audience
now watching and obsessing over the show
like everyone else but I'm like I have
no clue who this is
okay we're nice to have checked Twitter
and seen who they're guessing which is
we think it's Rob Gronkowski and I still
don't know who that is so that would be
why I really don't know who this is it's
okay we did the research for you you
know the big thing would the white tiger
for me is their performance ability so
this is someone who is larger-than-life
big movements you see this sprinkler you
see the running man he said in his clue
package that he loves a good block party
this is someone who just loves to party
and live life to the fullest Oh Rob
Gronkowski always partying on the
football field and off the football
field what do you think well we can
definitely tell it's an athlete because
I'm just gonna say that the vocals
aren't quite there we heard a backing
track tonight throughout the entire song
but he gave a fun performance and I did
love it for that also a few other clues
we saw in the package this one is uh
this one's a little tough we saw a
skiing cow poster what does it mean what
does it mean well we looked on Gronk's
Instagram and he does go skiing he does
love winter sports other than being on
the football field so I'm gonna count
down as one does that make any sense to
you not as I'm still confused about he's
a football player with us we'll start
there it's worth the last clue that we
want to point out is the boom box we saw
a boom box in the clue package and the
Pats actually went viral for this clip
of them partying in the locker room with
a big boom box Wow after they won the
Super Bowl I think that's what's so dope
about the show is that you just never
know who they are and there's somebody
for everybody you know what I mean like
somebody that's a total sports fanatic
would be like this is so cool that's
what I love about the show absolutely
and he recently retired so this is like
a really cool new way for him to explore
any super cool career yeah badass we
love you Krunk
you and next up we saw the kangaroo sing
you know I'm no good well we do know the
kangaroo is pretty good especially at
singing check it out
[Music]
did you have that same reaction I
thought that she was absolutely
incredible I couldn't really figure out
who it was I was unsure who it was I did
think it was kind of awesome that that
was one of the songs that was on my wish
list to perform when I was flamingo like
you can give yeah you get to give like a
wish list of the songs that you would
love to perform and they have to
obviously get them cleared and that was
one of the songs that I wished for so to
see somebody performing I was like yes
my song was done yeah but I thought she
did an absolute this person is in my
opinion obviously a vocalist they are a
singer can I put you on the spot yeah
yeah can we hear just a little like I
was Tanqueray but you're my fellow my
guy
something something man if I knew the
words the words we put you on the spot
good but you know okay so let's first of
all declare who we think okay so we we
stood here on superbowl night and we
thought confident confidently that we
thought it was Jordin Sparks former
winner of America's I know really good
guess well a lot of the clues seem to
point towards Jordin Sparks and she just
had a baby it's not a baby which they
said my little baby rule correct
she's someone who suffered loss
unfortunately in her life and we saw a
horseshoe in the word outback Jordan has
sang the national anthem at the Kentucky
Derby so I think with this show it's
really difficult because you can take
clues and interpret them however you
interpret that so we listened again this
week to this performance and it's pretty
clear it's I think Jordan has a higher
pitched voice son I think we go ahead we
got it halfway right it's not Jordin
Sparks we think it's Jordan woods
okay let's tell you why let's pull up
the clue packet wait what's your why is
your reaction that right now I'm just
confused
that's just so like it just feels a
little random exactly well okay let's
talk about the clue package and then I
want to dissect a little further so if
we can throw up the kangaroo court
reference in the clue package but she
doesn't have a new baby so you can see
it's written kangaroo court notice the
letter K we know that Jordan is a
with the Kardashian family we also saw
makeup so they're on this basketball
court and on the bench we saw an
assortment of makeup there now you know
Jordan did a collaboration with her
former best friend Kylie Jenner they put
out a line together under Kylie
cosmetics I think we have a CLIA there
they are a new tube talking about it
together what evidence do you have I'm
getting into the sports of it all she
also saw a basketball on the court
during this super active she actually
has an active wear line this also could
nod to her scandal last year with NBA
player Tristan Thompson also we saw the
number 23 on those jerseys you could
kind of see him in the back there she
was born on 923 oh wow so are you are
you buying bikes literally detectives
for you try this is our job this is what
we do the focal has she ever said that
she's a singer or that she likes to sing
or that she would want to sing while we
know that she is now no longer really in
the shadows of the Kardashian family
she's really emerging on her own she's
been in music videos she did an acting
stint on groan ish we hadn't really
heard her sing but we do have a little
sample of Jordan singing on Jaden
Smith's Instagram story during her
birthday celebration
take a listen I need
[Music]
so you can't hear a whole lot and it
sounds like Jaden is singing louder yeah
but I don't know is that an indicator I
feel like my spirit my spirit was
telling me that the original guess was
close closer oh yeah and we're doing
like number I like guess number one and
the only reason why I think that is cuz
you could say oh Jordan has a higher
voice but as a vocalist you just moving
around a little bit drink sing the song
lower yeah okay and the the judges
actually through some interesting names
out there Robin said Candace Parker who
is a WNBA player so clearly got that
from the basketball clue there Jason
Biggs who was the guest judge tonight
said Tatyana Ali and Jenny McCarthy said
Gabrielle Union that's the one that
doesn't do it for me no yeah I was like
that would be amazed how Boston with a I
love Gabrielle yeah and but I just don't
think this is her no I want to go back
to what you brought up now you mentioned
Jordan did recently have a baby and this
is a memory with a little rude pouch
they specifically said I need to do this
for my lip I need to like well Rou well
Jordan has younger siblings and I think
she's a very maternal figure I do know
that and I know she looks out for her
younger siblings so again this show they
love to give us a little something and
you crazy and I love it I don't know let
us know what you guys think Adrienne's
clearly on Team Jordan sparks we're not
on Team Jordan would I know it's a
little kind of between the two now I
can't wait till like this comes out I'm
gonna be hitting you you were right or
you were so next up we have the turtle
who's saying say you won't let go and
though certainly you don't want to let
the turtle go
No
it cool with now
I want your immediate reaiiy I think
that's the best vocal so far on this
season what makes it so good other than
shock of course yeah I feel like that's
a legend an icon um
this person can really really say yeah
like you can tell this is diamond those
licks and those runs at the end were so
perfect so precise so OnPoint the
stylistics of his vocal is amazing like
just the style like you can tell when
somebody's a professional singer he's
comfortable he's in you know the salt
like I just definitely think this is a
professional singer well so we think
this is Jesse McCartney I cheated and
went online I go straight to Twitter all
you got to do is write the turtle and
the masked singer and you will see who
everyone is guessing well and it's Jesse
McCartney's the number one that came up
well I want to ask you because you're
very much from the MTV generation I know
he was really big in the MTV generation
the Disney generation as well did your
paths ever cross never I think we may
have met at like a Radio Disney show
back in the day but I don't know him
like that but he's got if that's him you
better your mob putting some singles we
miss you in the music scene like come
through Jesse coming through should we
get into the glue pack a little what
gave it away for you so we saw on menu
can we pull up the the image of the menu
that we have we decoded these clues so
if you can see at the bottom it says
ginger snaps Jesse's mom is named ginger
then at the top sneaky sneaky Dover sold
now solace spelled Sol e I took it and
kind of twisted it a little Jessie's
arguably most popular song is beautiful
soul obviously a different type of song
but I thought you look we've got ginger
and we've got soul kinda it feels like
it's working in that right yes well
there yes we also saw pulling the fire
alarm we saw a clip of him literally
pulling the fire alarm in the clue
package they rebel like a rebel well
also I looked this up and apparently
there's a quote that jesse has said he
has terrible terrible luck with getting
up in the morning so he makes his mom he
makes his manager he makes his friends
call him oh my gosh to make sure that he
arrives on Saturdays whatever it is he
has to do that day that's amazing so
alarm literally holy
to wake him up and at the end we
actually saw most likely his most likely
was most likely to hunt for booty I know
and he's done it often is what we heard
him say so
booty pirates that kind of goes together
while his first film was actually 2001
the Pirates of Central Park that's a
[ __ ] anyone now he said often so
clearly there's another one there in
2016 on AMC's fear of The Walking Dead
he played read a member of another cast
members pirate group and we know there
was another allusion to the word act yes
so we know this is someone who not only
has insane vocal chops but they have
acted yes completely so I don't know the
only thing that really threw me is this
orange guitar we could not lose this
darn orange guitar and I don't know what
it means if you guys let us know please
tell us what's the orange guitar what's
the heart guitar and it wasn't just any
kind orange but I was a fool you know
more guitar yeah the real deal right
this talk on that one well before we
wrap up we are gonna give our very first
reality check of the season yes now you
know we love you judges but sometimes
we've got to give you a little dose of
your own reality because some of these
guesses are wack AF tonight's reality
check goes to Ken take a look okay dig
dis from the clue package Titanic she
sang the theme to Titanic French
monsters in the clue she's
french-canadian Celine Dion stay with me
Celine Dion's got range where she can
disguise her voice where she could sing
a song like that surprise people are
going it's kind of K like someone please
go check on Ken do you have Ken number
one this is a stretch I mean this is a
stretch I mean he you were on the show
you know how insane some of his guesses
he just recently had Robin Thicke on the
real and I literally had to ask him I'm
like why did you keep guessing that I
was Fantasia like that was just so
Audrey and it was one of the greatest
compliments ever cuz Sanitation is one
of the greatest vocalists and performers
of like ever but before you I was like
that just a little off though yeah say
it just a little longer
look Queen Celine
we would love to see you - how amazing
that would be just on another level I
mean we've had Patti we've had hopefully
shot the Gladys Knight guys such iconic
people little Wayne wheezy little Tucci
your night go it's a big deal
listen Celine and we track her cuz we
love her so much she's on tour right now
guys she started her courage world tour
in September 2019 and she's gonna be on
the road until September 22 I'm going to
see her at the Staples Center you guys
we are so thrilled that miss Queen
Adrienne Bailon join us tonight
any last thoughts predictions things you
want to mention um I don't know I'm
super excited I honestly believe that
doing this show is one of the greatest
experiences of my career
so not only do i watch it excited for
just figuring out who it is but I'm
excited for those people are they behind
the mass because I know that what
they're going through is pretty awesome
and the courage that it takes to do this
is insane so I'm just so excited for
this season I can't believe it's back
how's your life changed since doing the
show it has I think in different ways I
think a lot of people now are like
we-forgot-you saying
so that's awesome and out hint you know
that means like you know like some new
tunes well have been super encouraging
and it's it's it's meant so much to me
so I guess it has been life changing for
sure thank you so much for joining us
of course we're here every Wednesday
recapping the master you're getting down
and dirty into those clue packages make
sure you join us next week I'm Deidre
Bay hi I'm Charlie O'Keefe and we'll see
you next week I was gonna say I'm
Adrienne Hilary okay bye
[Music]